hello and welcome to the seventh PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be covering basically just the operators
right you have assignment operators
comparison operators and logical
operators and so if you don't know what
those means just yet don't worry I'm
going to explain them
so first let's do a little quick comment
if you remember we're gonna do a
multi-line comment and that's going to
be just forward slash star and then star
forward slash to close that off and
within here let's go over some of the
operators so the first one I think we
should do of course is assignment
operator but luckily we've already done
that and these this is an assignment
operator just a single equal sign you're
just saying this equals this so we've
already really covered those not going
to write it out it's just defining
something the next thing we should do is
the comparison operators cuz these will
start getting pretty useful so far we've
sort of done a comparison operator as
far as equal equal as is concerned but
let's do some of the other comparisons
and so those are of course you've got
greater than less than then there's less
than or equal to greater than or equal
to then you've got this where it's like
it's not it's just it's almost like it
does not equal but I wouldn't really
suggest using that I think the easier
way to read it out is like this with
exclamation mark equal that means does
not equal then you can also do things
like is not less than write is not
greater than so those are your
comparison operators and so you can see
here like we've got a greater than or
equal to 999 so if age is greater than
or equal to 999 echo true else if age
equals 99 and in fact let's just go
ahead and delete this else if
heart just so we're not you know
confusing anybody and so then we'll run
so with age is greater than or equal to
99 will echo true and then otherwise
we'll just echo false so that's R
greater than or equal to we'll upload
this to the server
let's come over here refresh false is
not the case that 99 is greater than or
equal to 999 then you can do if age does
not equal 999 then we want to echo true
otherwise false let's put that up on the
server
come over here afresh true it doesn't
equal 999 and so on you get the idea you
can use all these comparison operators
for that finally there are logical
operators and the logical operators are
as follows they go double Ansem which
just means and so like if age and day
let's just do this age day equals so if
you you could say like if age and day
are less than 999 that go true let's
just try that for an example nice and
I'll throw that up to the server up we
gotta do this okay
oops going on over here okay refresh so
if you do like if age and day or less
than 999 that go true we save that throw
it up on a server refresh you do get a
true they are less than but what if this
one was you know 1555 you can save that
we'll run that and it's false because
one of them is not it's not true but
then what if you said we can use the or
which is just like two bars basically
say that run it so one of these is not
and but one of these is your refresh and
you get a true because only one of them
has to be so that's it with the
assignment comparison and logical
operators next up we've got arithmetics
I know you're excited